hi everybody welcome to the set of  Jungle Cruise I'm so excited to welcome  you to this incredible movie as you can  see we have a beautiful path lit behind  us usually to show people when you have  the beautiful path and then you have the  beautiful co-star Wow no I think this  was just sorry I just I'm here no no I  just this was just supposed to be you  we're telling me hey let's be like  Humphrey Bogart and and Kathleen Hepburn  Kathleen or is it Kathryn it's what do  you research okay  Michael Douglas Kathleen Turner that's  it that's right Fred Astaire Ginger  Rogers we're never in the jungle so it's  a love story it is a love story yes  welcome to Jungle Cruise it's gonna be  great the adventure of a lifetime wait  sorry I'm sorry wait come back one  second come on back they're kidding  welcome to the adventure of a lifetime  no no I did  you